we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman hydrant is the delicious
fruit drink powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drink hydrant.com pacman and
use the code pacman
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started so my goal my
priority since the start of the
coronavirus pandemic has
been to be accurately alarmist for the
information that we have and there was a
period
back in i think it was december january
where i was getting emails from people
saying david you're overly alarmist this
isn't going to be anything
and then there was maybe a little period
sort of like in may
where i was maybe more optimistic about
the situation
than some in the audience but i i think
that i've done an
okay job at more or less accurately
communicating the sort of status of the
situation and the outlook with the
pandemic
and i have what i think is some
accurately
but cautiously optimistic news for you
today
and although the timing of it is
interesting this is not a political
comment
but there is a mathematical coincidence
pointing to
um a case and death peak
hopefully the last one of the pandemic
right around the time of joe biden's
inauguration now
i'm not making a political segment out
of this it's mere coincidence when we
i'll show you the math
and the trajectories but it seems as
though right around january 20th the day
that joe biden will be sworn in
as president that we will be starting
to get past what is hopefully the last
peak
of this pandemic and again it's a
coincidence i'm not claiming january
20th
joe biden will be sworn in and covid
will be fixed it is
merely a timing coincidence and we know
that these peaks
depend on what happens in the weeks and
months leading up
but i want to go through it with you
because it does feel like we're starting
to get
into the tunnel at least we're maybe
seeing the light or maybe not but we're
definitely
in the part of the tunnel that we would
consider the latter part of the tunnel
now as you
may know we've had three coronavirus
peaks in the united states
many countries have only had two we've
had three first one was in april
second one was in july and the third one
is right now
and in this third peak we've seen cases
spike all the way up to close to 250
000 cases in a single day mostly in the
low 200s
210 215 000 and what you can also see
when looking at the case graph
if you're watching along with me today
is that over the last 10 days
the rate of case growth has slowed down
meaning the curve
flattened and it even turned downwards
in the last few days now it is quite
possible that there's still
one more peak to go fueled by holiday
and end-of-year travel
and indoor gatherings we shouldn't do
them
it's sort of a foregone conclusion that
no matter what i say many people are
going to do them but
the rate of case growth in the u.s at a
at a large broad level is slowing down
looking at the predictions and the
models from a variety of epidemiologists
and other experts the case
peak is expected to be right around the
end of this
of the first week of january you know
january 7 8 9 10 11 12.
very rough estimate and we know that
deaths lag
cases by about three weeks and when you
look at the deaths chart right now
you see a similar pattern to cases
and while in this third peak we've
started
to see the cases come down a bit
we are only seeing the growth of death
slow down so
we we likely are about three weeks
behind in terms of deaths where we are
in cases so if we see a case peak around
call it january 10th
to pick a date we would expect to see a
death peak right around february 1.
in all likelihood and this doesn't
justify getting careless
it doesn't do anything to change the
tragic death and destruction that the
virus has already brought to date but
in all likelihood that in january
will be the final peak of this pandemic
unless something dramatic changes
why because that will not only be the
worst moment in terms of weather and
people being indoors
december january is the coldest time of
the year in the parts of the us that
have winter
but as the temperature warms and the
days get longer and people spend more
time outside we will also have the
benefit of the vaccination program
vaccination has started in the u.s
we have the approved vaccine from pfizer
emergency use approval
second vaccine from moderna expected to
be approved for emergency use tomorrow
third vaccine may be in the first
quarter of the new year so at the same
time that we will be peaking in cases
and deaths with the coldest weather and
the most people indoors
we will have if all goes to plan all
health care workers vaccinated by
february 1st
all nursing home residents vaccinated by
february 1st and we will be in the
process of vaccinating
that next most vulnerable group which
will include the oldest folks and those
with the most serious comorbidities and
by protecting
an additional five to seven percent of
the population each month
starting now going into january february
march
that peak we're expecting in january is
likely to be the final one and have a
more rapid decline than without
vaccination so this is all
excellent news but there is still a big
battle here
we're still going to have to do all the
things we've been many of us have been
doing not all of us
masks social distancing avoiding indoor
gatherings but it is mathematically
looking like we're potentially about
three weeks from the case peak
of the pandemic and five to six weeks
from the death peak
and at that point the vaccination
program will be more robust
with millions of vaccinations weekly so
there is a light there
that's the good news now given this
we should be extra cautious in these
next months because we're so close it's
not like
listen this is gonna go on for two or
three more years
and we might be well uh for
psychological reasons maybe we take a
screw it attitude and just have a good
time
starting now we will see five-ish
percent of the country vaccinated each
month that's huge
and we are close to deaths and cases
starting to decline
so the message is that's the math of it
those are the expectations that's where
vaccination is
we're just a couple months away from
significantly better circumstances my
friends
so let's do everything that we can uh we
have been
speculating about the future of the
trump
family with regard to vaccination
uh i'm sorry with regard to
investigation my mind is still uncovered
once donald trump is no longer president
of the united states
and we got some news that might be a
sort of a signal about what we are to
expect once donald trump is out of
office
and that's that a state judge ruled
yesterday that the trump
organization must turn over documents
related to a property
whose tax abatements are being
investigated by the new york attorney
general
um uh and and can will continue to be
investigated and these are
this is still going on these are
documents that the trump organization
this is trump's business
previously claimed were protected by
attorney-client
privilege and a a judge has decided
that that is not the case the attorney
general argued these documents are not
privileged partially because the trump
organization
waived privilege when it disclosed
certain documents to the irs
to gain benefit and a judge agreed
and we've heard this story before and
many will say
hasn't this been ordered before and they
still haven't turned over the documents
and that is true so what is the
difference why do we care about this
we care about this for for really two
primary reasons
number one soon donald trump is no
longer going to be president
and while it wasn't a big part of this
case
there are all sorts of other
investigations going on into donald
trump and his
business and his uh finances and his
family's finances
um and donald trump is soon not going to
be able to hide behind
i'm the president and this is a burden
because i am the president
that's something his lawyers have
frequently used to try to make the case
that he should be left alone
and they've done it to some degree of
success that opportunity goes away
in 35 days i believe it is and that's
going to change this
dramatically number two
the legal fees are going to become
outrageous even for trump
and not only is donald trump i mean
listen
he can keep trying to raise money for
for legal fees on the basis of
i don't know running and maybe that's
why he'll announce that he's running in
2024
to be able to raise money which he could
maybe legally maybe not
redirect to to legal fees even if that's
a violation of campaign finance law we
don't that's not clear yet
uh but we have this we have rumors that
donald trump
is absolutely horrified about the
possibility of being deposed
in the sexual assault case brought by eg
carroll if that name rings a bell it
should
because we talked about her in 2016 and
2017. that was on hold
while donald trump was president he will
soon not be president
every indication that that story and
that case is going to come back in
and donald trump reportedly horrified
about maybe being deposed
in that case and these legal fees are
going to build
as the legal protections for trump as
president evaporate
and uh that could dramatically encumber
trump
over the next who knows how many years
so this could all get
really wild in the six to 12 months
after donald trump leaves office
we talked about starting to see the
light at the end of the tunnel as far as
the pandemic is concerned
i'm starting to see the light at the end
of the tunnel in terms of the trump
administration
and it's going to be a bad couple of
months
in terms of the virus it's going to be a
chaotic couple of months
in terms of the maga people and the cue
and honors
having to adjust to this reality of joe
biden as president there's the
possibility of violence
we can never get back the lives lost due
to trump's mishandling of the virus etc
etc
but if you zoom out a little bit
vaccination has started
trump is leaving joe biden is coming in
we have early voting starting in georgia
with democrats still possibly taking the
senate
and the investigations into donald trump
are starting
with numerous now favorable decisions by
judges
now will they ever get the documents
that the judge said have to be turned
over
maybe and the truth is that these
particular documents
like this isn't really even the
bombshell case the point here is
at some point trump is going to run out
of appeals
and or run out of run out of money for
appeals in terms of legal fees
and if and when that happens and i
believe it's more a matter of when
rather than
if uh this is going to become a very
complicated 2021 for donald trump
very quickly make sure you're following
me on twitter
where you can find me at the pacman
we're going to take a quick break
and uh it's really a packed show today
let's actually
keep a record of this one because this
one i think is going to be pretty good
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do
is take thousands of popular nonfiction
books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show is mostly funded
by
members who sign up at joinpackman.com i
will not waste
any more time talking about it because
we have such a busy agenda
but uh i invite you to grab a membership
at jointpakman.com where you can also
read about all the great membership
benefits
okay up hatred mail has become managing
the hate mail we have been getting since
joe biden won the election on november
3rd
november 7th as it was called by the
media um
it's almost a job in and of itself the
hate mail has so scaled up
and i have one such example for you
today but first a quick reminder
what is hatred mail exactly
last time i checked this was america and
i have the right to share my
droplets with whoever i want
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate david pakman
because america and because
freedom right so hatred mail is when a
professional voice-over artist does
interpretive readings
of the hate mail that i get and
um here is you know we don't we could do
five shows a week of just an hour of
hate mail at this point we really could
but here is just one example for you to
take a listen to
david pakman is a frustrated loser
the show is circling the drain million
subscribers 50 millions views per month
lol how much did you pay
socal blad almost two years later and
david is more
cucked than ever sore loser
yes you lost spell loser with a
d-a-v-i-d
you are a shill and a fraud keep it up
i love those credentials you know did i
learned some stuff
from the hey i i didn't realize that we
had 50 million views
in a 30-day period but we we actually
did which is insane and i appreciate
this hatred for uh
for for letting me know about these
stunning numbers i i love it
the part that's confusing to me is what
does we
lost mean like what exactly what what
did we lose
joe biden won right and i i got into an
interesting uh
facebook exchange yesterday against my
better judgment with some friends
with so a couple people not my friends
but there are people in the thread
who believe that trump will be sworn in
for a second term on january 20th and
here's my question to you
should we be betting these people money
and what i mean is
i'm not a betting man i don't really bet
um
but it seems as though there's money to
be made
betting money against the people who say
trump will be sworn in on january 20th
if they really believe that
i'd bet 100 i'd bet a thousand dollars
i'd even look at betting more
but i heard from people who tried this
with family members and they said that
the family members eventually backed out
typically coming up with some excuse
like well listen
it's all rigged like if if it weren't
rigged
trump would be getting sworn in so i'm
no longer participating in the bet which
is of course the point of the bet the
point of the bet
is will trump be sworn in not
would trump be sworn in if right as i
said before if my grandmother had wheels
instead of legs she would be a bicycle
it's not
well trump would have been sworn in were
it not quote rigged
the bet is will he be sworn in that
seems like easy money to me
but maybe it's taking advantage of
people who can't even think straight let
me know what your thoughts are
and remember that the way to fight
patriotism in your community
is to use the coupon code hatred 40 when
you get a membership this is a code that
has been often used
much imitated never equaled hatred 40
saves you 40 at joinpakman.com and it's
spelled h
a t r i o t
four zero okay uh donald trump's
press secretary and senior campaign
advisor
kaylee mcinanni held a press briefing
yesterday
and if anything has become clear in the
last five weeks
it's that she is absolutely determined
and committed to going down with the
ship
in the most humiliating way possible
kaylee mac and anna you may remember it
feels like a decade ago
but it was not that long ago i don't
remember how long ago it was
on her first day in the press briefing
room as white house press secretary
kaley promised the media she would never
lie to them
and she would never lie to the american
people but i know i know
but uh she's she's done nothing but lie
ever since
so let's look at some highlights or
really i guess they would be low lights
from what is closer and closer to being
her last briefing as white house press
secretary
she's asked the question understandably
logically
about the fact and it is a fact that the
electoral college has voted
will donald trump now acknowledge that
he lost given
that the electoral college has voted on
monday and without a shred of irony
kaylee mcinanni refers the question to
the campaign
of which she is a senior advisor
remember
ben kelly uh now that the electoral
college has voted does the president
acknowledge that joe biden is the
president-elect does he have any plans
to invite him here to the white house
um the president is still involved in
ongoing litigation related to the
election
uh yesterday's vote was one step in the
constitutional process so
i will leave that to him and refer you
to the campaign for more on that
litigation what was his reaction to uh
leader mcconnell today
congratulating joe biden and calling him
the president-elect
i haven't gotten the president's
reaction to that yet but the president
again is pursuing ongoing litigation
would refer you to the campaign for
further
what's the point forward though for
litigation if the votes have been
certified if the electoral college has
voted there doesn't seem to be a legal
recourse at this point
the campaign would have more specifics
for you on legal recourse but yesterday
was one step in the constitutional
process
leading up to the january 20th date in
the constitution
this is such a tired farcical game that
she's been playing
if it's convenient she's the white house
press secretary
and if it's convenient she's the white
house if she's the trump campaign senior
advisor
and you're gonna have to ask the other
entity about that uh that
that question it's actually completely
embarrassing at this point and she
doesn't care
she just keeps using that to avoid
answering questions
no question is simple for kaylee
mcinanni the answer is always weird she
was
asked a pretty straightforward question
will trump take the vaccine
and she says trump is open to taking the
vaccine well but will he take it
we don't actually get an answer to that
part does the president plan to take the
vaccine
and really do it in a public way to
inspire confidence among people
so the president currently at this
moment i said he is
absolutely open to taking the vaccine
he's been emphatic about that
to me privately and to you all publicly
but he did recently recover from covid
he has the continued protective effects
of the monoclonal antibody cocktail that
i mentioned
and he will receive the vaccine as soon
as his medical team determines its best
but
his priority is frontline workers those
in long-term care facilities and he
wants to make sure that the vulnerable
get
access first yes wouldn't him taking the
vaccine set an example for americans to
give them confidence
doctors uh dr bauchi as well as the
month of louisville said today
that they think president trump should
get the vaccine if
they you know because for himself would
be to set an example
will he do that like why not do it just
to show americans that it's safe
because he also wants to show americans
that our priority are the most
most vulnerable there will be some
senior administration
officials taking it publicly to instill
that confidence it is very important
this is not merely a cop-out answer
it's actually dangerous because kaylee
cites as a reason maybe trump doesn't
need the vaccine the fact that he had
coronavirus and recovered for it so he
has naturally derived immunity
that's still a question mark why when
you know that the followers of this
president
are disproportionately anti-science
trump brown-nosers who will do anything
they can
to excuse behaving less safely we don't
know how long immunity lasts after a
recovery from the virus that's an open
question
we don't know whether you have stronger
longer lasting more robust immunity
if you recover from a serious case of
the virus versus if you had one of those
asymptomatic cases we just these are
open
questions and it's irresponsible for her
to be saying that maybe trump doesn't
really need the vaccine
or needs it less because he recovered
for the from the virus
cdc guidelines and equivalent guidelines
around the world from
from other country health agencies
are regardless of whether you've had the
virus when a vaccine becomes available
you should get the vaccine
moving on kaylee again says that donald
trump
will veto military funding partially
because he's angry at twitter
do you know when specifically when the
president will veto the national defense
authorization act when he's going to
send the paperwork over
and why would he veto that given the
fact that passed on veto proof
majorities in congress
so he still does plan to veto the ndaa
i don't have a timeline for you on that
but he does plan to veto it
he wants to make every effort to protect
our military men and women
and will prioritize military funding in
the big omnibus bill but
he also has other important priorities
and i should say problems with the ndaa
beyond just the absence of section 230
repeal
and beyond the inclusion of the warren
amendment one of the
provisions of concern is troop
provisions about troop withdrawal and
deployment in afghanistan south korea
and germany and so there are a number of
provisions that um
so i let me remind you about that trump
has talked about this section 230 thing
section 230 is a provision
which essentially says that
if there is uh illegal libelous
or otherwise uh problematic content on a
platform like twitter or youtube
it is not twitter or youtube that are
liable it's whoever posts it that is
liable
and donald trump believes that if you
eliminate
section 230 a lot of anti-trump
trends would be shut down like for
example
when donald trump sat at that tiny desk
and
attacked people on thanksgiving day and
then the hashtag
diaperdon trended on twitter diaper
dawn's sort of an allusion to
um the petulant child that is donald
trump
trump went crazy talking about section
230 section 230 if we get rid of it
twitter would never allow diaper dawn to
trend now
there's really no legal liability with
diaper don a hashtag about
not just a public person but one of the
most powerful public figures in the
world
so that actually wouldn't change diaper
dawn from trending but what trump seems
not to understand is that if section 230
is eliminated
he likely gets banned from twitter
because of the things he posts
to twitter which are wrong public health
disinformation
election disinformation posts that
direct bullying
against individuals trump seems to to
think his problems go away if section
230 goes away
in fact he probably gets banned from
twitter if section 230 goes away all
right so that's
that's that to get back on track kaylee
continues to allude to
a second trump term starting on january
20th
it's all coded language but here she
refers to
listen we're ready for a transition
and we're also ready for a continuation
of power and either might happen
the electoral college has voted it it's
over but kaylee continues to to play
this game
biden's cabinet picks president trump
had the benefit
of the senate starting hearings and
starting the process before he was
inaugurated in january
of 2017. does the president oppose
the senate taking up joe biden's
nominees before the inauguration
i think that's a hypothetical um and you
know he won't get ahead of
that activity actually happening but he
has taken all statutory
requirements um necessary to in either
ensure a smooth transition or a
continuation of power
just absolutely out of her mind there's
no
there's no caveat here there's no
mitigating factor
she's just pushing nonsense the
electoral college voted
on monday uh joe biden has 270 actually
306 electoral votes
they're gaslighting people that's all it
is and they continue to raise money on
it trump as recently as yesterday
sending out emails saying
i need to raise a million dollars in the
next
hour or day or whatever it was um kaylee
asked why hasn't donald trump been more
visible during the vaccine rollout i
mean this is this is happening
and shouldn't he be there we barely see
the president where has he been he has
nothing on his schedule ever
and uh kaylee with a straight face says
this because trump's been so busy
working
why hasn't president trump been more
visible
during this initial vaccine rollout
you're the vice president
in indiana today where's president trump
president trump's been hard at work on
covid behind the scenes just because you
don't see him at the podium every day
doesn't mean that he's not aggressively
pursuing actions on behalf of the
american people
he's briefed on kovitt regularly and i'm
here speaking with you guys others
are out communicating this information
all the things she's talking about
working behind the scenes meetings
working on kovid
his public schedule is blank every day
it
is the argument now of course when the
president there are things that are off
a president's public schedule that the
president does
uh but is the argument that just like
having meetings about the vaccine
are so secret that they can't even be on
trump's schedule it's just more lies
trump is doing nothing
every report from inside the the white
house is that trump is doing nothing
and then the sort of denumont here as
she walks out
is she she of course walks out after
taking very few questions and not
answering any of them
in in any real way you hear in this next
clip as she's walking out of the press
briefing room
i love this cnn's jim acosta asking
kaylee isn't it hypocritical for you to
accuse others of spreading
disinformation when you spread it every
day
a beautiful question someone like trump
might call it a nasty question but it's
an important question take a listen
really interesting turn of events and
good for those who covered what was a
story all along and not
russia disinformation isn't it
hypocritical for you to accuse others of
disinformation when you spread it every
day
in a logical world okay if
actions had logical consequences no one
would want to employ
kaylee mcinanny after this absolute
insanity of a white house press
secretary
tenure unfortunately we know
that she likely is going to end up
with some kind of very cushy gig
either i don't know as a consultant at
some
right-wing organization or doing
communications for a company that has
right-wing leanings or
who knows but she is going to have a
very soft landing don't
if she should be unemployable based on
the the deceit and the lies
but she's going to have a fine landing
if you were worried about where kaylee
goes after this don't you don't don't
worry about it at all
we'll have more coverage of this and
clips on the show's instagram page
at david pakman show and if you want to
see what happened to my umbrella
in very very powerful boston winds make
sure you're following me on instagram at
david.pakman
a video that has taken i guess i was
going to save the world by storm
not really a video that has taken my
followers by storm
uh me barely able to handle an umbrella
in boston wind that's on my
personal instagram david.pacman we'll
take a quick break
up next mitch mcconnell he finally did
it what is it that he did
we'll talk about it in two minutes the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great
it's made with real fruit juice it's
been a great part of my daily routine
for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant
immunity packed with vitamins a b c and
d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show if
there's anybody approximating a king
maker remaining
in the republican party to some degree
it is actually 78 year old republican
senate majority leader
mitch mcconnell and love him or hate him
and i don't like the guy
he has been one of the most effective
republicans in the last decade at just
getting things done when republicans
want to do something and blocking
democrats from doing things when
republicans don't want them doing things
the merrick garland
supreme court nomination certainly comes
to mind and
immediately following joe biden's formal
elector
electoral college win on monday where
each state's electors
voted and confirmed that indeed joe
biden has 270 electoral votes
mitch mcconnell acknowledged joe biden's
win and congratulated
joe biden now this is not praise of
mitch mcconnell mitch mcconnell
avoided acknowledging that joe biden won
for five weeks after the election
even when it was obvious that joe biden
had won this is not about mitch
mcconnell being a good guy
it's once again even someone as horrible
as mitch mcconnell
as unwilling to admit what is there and
plain to see as mitch mcconnell
is saying joe biden won effectively
ending
any remote possibility that the
republican party would insist
that joe biden didn't really win here is
mitch mcconnell
yesterday on the floor of the u.s senate
take a listen
but our system of government has
processes to determine
who will be sworn in on january the 20th
the electoral college has spoken
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden
the president-elect is no stranger to
the senate he's devoted himself to
public service
for many years i also want to
congratulate the vice president-elect
our colleague from california senator
harris
beyond our differences all americans can
take pride that our nation has a female
vice president-elect
for the very first time i look forward
to finishing out the next 36 days
strong with president trump our nation
needs us to add another bipartisan
chapter
to this record of achievement so this is
important for a few reasons
number one this signals that there's
really nothing left for trump i mean
truly nothing to try
to steal this election now i know that
the q anon people
and the cultists and even trump himself
and you know kaylee mcinanny as we saw
earlier
they're going to continue acting as if
there's more to do maybe jenna ellis is
going to
if she's recovered from coronavirus
they're going to keep going but
when even the senate majority on january
6 who do you think is going to interfere
with joe biden officially being a
president-elect
in terms of congress accepting the votes
it would be members of the republican
party in the house and senate and the
senate majority leader here has said
congratulations to joe biden so
it signals the the emptying of the bag
of tricks
so to speak but secondly this is also
relevant and important for people who
were
dreaming of something to happen
uh sometime between now and the
inauguration that would slow down or
prevent joe biden swearing in
when mitch mcconnell acknowledges the
president-elect
it really makes that dream or really
it's a nightmare
it makes it all but an impossibility and
we also learned that mitch mcconnell and
joe biden spoke after this
congratulations
here's joe biden briefly speaking to the
media yesterday
telling us how that call with mitch
mcconnell went i had a good conversation
with mitch
mcconnell today he talked to him i
called him to thank him for the
congratulations
told him well we disagree on a lot of
things those things we can work together
on
we've always been stable on one another
and
uh we agreed we get together sooner than
later
and i'm looking forward to working with
them i just want to know i spoke with
them
i've been calling other members i spoke
with some other members as well there's
about a dozen calling
and as i kick them off i'll tell you who
i've spoken to okay
thank you so that's straightforward and
to the point there so slowly but surely
all of the remaining eyes are dotted and
t's are crossed
to nobody's surprise except for the
millions of trump cultists who thought
that this might go
some other way now my only concern about
what joe biden said continues to be the
same one i've had from before the
election
i hope that joe biden is merely paying
lip service to the idea of getting
things done with mitch mcconnell
because it would be cartoonishly naive
to think that this republican party
is going to work with you on anything
and as i've said before
the only way you would get this
republican party to work with you on
anything there's there's two scenarios
in which this republican party might
help you
one is if they determine that getting in
the way of what you're working on
would actually hurt them electorally
like if you if they determine imagine
that there's no stimulus past now and
biden gets to oversee a second stimulus
if republicans determine that not doing
a second stimulus is bad for them
they might actually come to the table
with joe biden but they would still try
to make it mostly for corporations
uh and not really for for individuals
the second scenario
where republicans would work with joe
biden or work with democrats in general
is if joe biden and democrats are
willing to accept
such outrageous compromise to get
republicans on board
that it becomes almost like a peric
victory where it's a victory on paper
but you may actually be doing
more harm than good in so working with
these republicans so
my concern continues to be the naivete
if joe biden
really thinks he's going to work with
these people he's not now
very quickly mitch mcconnell became
enemy number one of the trump cult we'll
do more about this later but just one
example for you here
this is a video clip of trump sycophant
charlie kirk actually saying
that this might be mitch mcconnell
ruining the chances in georgia of the
republican candidates by acknowledging
that joe biden won
and so if mitch mcconnell wants to wake
up on january
6th and
be met with two of his senate candidates
all of a sudden trailing in georgia
keep talking like this go out of your
way
to use the term congratulate
if he had to and was getting pressure he
could have at the very most
today i will recognize i probably would
have taken exception with that
but the term congratulations inherently
means that you are applauding and
recognizing
an achievement of success
when do you use congratulations in your
life
when people attain athletic
accomplishments when people get married
engaged
you typically don't use the term
congratulations
when someone just stole a bank i love
that
charlie going full on he's charlie
doesn't even stop at robbing a bank
he says it's like stealing the entire
bank just picking up the whole bank and
taking it really fascinating stuff so
this is a similar situation to some
trumpists
who now think fox news is liberal and
part of the problem the idea
that someone as wretchedly conservative
as mitch mcconnell
might not be a strong enough right
winger just shows you how extreme the
trump cult has become
but understand that part of this is
calculation by mitch
mitch knows they don't have the votes to
actually stop joe biden from being
president they
he knows they can't do anything and
mitch mcconnell
wants to get back to the standard
partisan bickering and republican
obstruction
of democrats as soon as possible and so
what mitch mcconnell is effectively
doing here is kind of ripping the
band-aid off
now and getting people back to reality
sooner get republicans back to being
united about
you know the deficit and stopping
anything democrats want to do so i i
actually
looking at it from the standpoint of
mitch mcconnell
i think what he's doing here actually
makes perfect sense it obviously makes
sense based on the votes biden won and
we knew that five weeks ago
but i think it also even is the right
strategy if your goal is
reunite the republican party and let's
get back to stopping joe biden from
doing a damn thing and they may well
succeed at it so we talked about
republican senator mitch mcconnell
ending the overt
farce that the last five weeks have been
and congratulating joe biden as
president-elect since after all
joe biden did win the election now we
immediately have the blowback to this
story
which is that almost instantly donald
trump himself
and trumpists including q anon
conspiracy theorists and others
immediately turned on mitch mcconnell
fomenting the republican civil war we
discussed earlier in the week
earlier this week i did a segment called
republican civil war
maga protesters chant destroy the
republican party
and that story generated quite a bit of
interest and in that segment
i said whether there is reconciliation
within the republican party as joe biden
becomes president will depend on trump
and what trump does now we um
have two sort of primary scenarios if
trump just shuts up and disappears to
play golf or do whatever
the republican party will come back
together the wackiest elements like
q anon will evaporate and you'll get
back to the pre-trump republican party
on the other hand
if donald trump and his most ardent
cultists keep going
you may have a protracted republican
civil war
and if it goes on for a few more weeks
it might actually hurt republicans in
the georgia senate runoffs which would
be great and it's looking more and more
like at least in the next month that
second scenario is the most likely
scenario
very late last night or early this
morning i think just after midnight
eastern time
donald trump took to twitter in response
to mitch mcconnell congratulating joe
biden
and acknowledging that joe biden won and
is the president-elect
trump tweeted and quoted from an article
and said
mitch 75 million votes
a record for a sitting president by a
lot
too soon to give up republican party
must finally learn to fight
people are angry and indeed right on cue
the q anon conspiracy theorists q anon
being this pro-trump
conspiracy ideology listed as a domestic
terror threat
by the fbi q anon conspiracy theorists
immediately started accusing mitch
mcconnell of working for the deep state
of being a rhino a republican in name
only which is pretty funny
which since he's the senate majority
leader many q anon
cultist accounts on social media said
they would be leaving the republican
party because mitch mcconnell
acknowledged
an empirical reality that joe biden won
the election
and the messages from the q anon people
ranged from you're a disgrace
mitch mcconnell to today marks the birth
of the america first party
to congratulations [ __ ] mcconnell today
marked
the death knell of the republican party
because of your treasonous
actions telling party members not to
back trump so a few thoughts on this all
relevant to the next two to four years
of american politics
first trump mad at mitch mcconnell
q on mad at mitch mcconnell trump mad at
the georgia governor brian kemp
this is a dream for democrats trying to
win these two senate seats and take
control
of the senate for the next two years
we've said the polling is close in
georgia
and it's really a toss-up i mean we've
got margins of one to two
in the polls that we're seeing for both
democratic challengers john ossoff
and rafael warnock you really can't
dream up a better scenario in a red
state where democrats are trying to win
then some republicans thinking it's
rigged against them and maybe staying
home
boycotting the election while others are
threatening to leave the party
you could not ask for a better scenario
as democratic
challengers trying to take over seats
currently held by republican incumbents
so
this little kerfuffle has the potential
to hand senate control to democrats
this also thinking more broadly this
also signals the future about something
we've talked
talked about before what happens to
trump is when trump leaves
do they simply become regular
republicans and start talking about
lowering taxes and regulations and
paying off the debt
because that's not what the q anon types
have been during the trump
cult peak years it seems to me
that for many of these q anon and trump
cultists
it's not going to be rewarding or
interesting it's going to be too milk
toast to just be
normal republicans and we might see some
of them leave politics all together
some maybe get involved in something
more radical and that's exactly the
signal that they're sending right now
now
just a funny side note on the mitch
mcconnell congratulations
thing vladimir putin and mitch mcconnell
both congratulated joe biden this week
for winning
trump only lashed out at mitch mcconnell
mean it's just it's poetically perfect
and it uh it continues to be
but we're getting closer to the end and
i want to remind you
january 1 21 so this is our
1-121 membership drive we want to start
the next year off
really powerfully so on january 1st we
are doing a one day
membership special it will be themed
based on the date so the special will be
related to
1-121 okay that's all i'm saying
if you want to be if you've been
thinking i kind of like what you do
david but
you know i don't really like your voice
or i don't really like the shape of your
mouth as someone wrote to me last week
but you like the content and you've been
thinking about supporting
get on our newsletter at davidpakman.com
and then on january 1 you will be
notified
perfectly with instructions as to how to
take advantage of this great membership
special
quick break back after this the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea
of going into a doctor's office right
now and
thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone
or video chat this is not a random
doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number
of patients so they actually have time
to listen to you you get
the personal attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do perform medical
evaluations
talk to you about health concerns send
prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month
with no other fees or copays there are
so many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz see which doctor is right for
you
i took their quiz they matched me with a
doctor who specializes in my particular
health needs and situation the doctor
they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
i have to admit that this story kind of
bums me out
and you'll understand why in a little
bit it relates
it relates to my youth in some sense um
fox business host maria bartoromo
is now sinking so low that that it's
actually depressing
um you i am sure at this point have
heard
that joe biden won the presidential
election that the electoral college
confirmed it
joe biden has most of his cabinet
selected donald trump lost in court
like 50 times or something like that the
supreme court has said no thanks to his
case
and fox business host maria bartoromo
now really a second-rate fox host even
by their standards
is a really aggressive trump brown-noser
and
claimed yesterday that an intel source
wait for it an intel source told her
donald trump actually won the election
let's look at the clip
and then i'm going to tell you about the
sort of tragic downfall
of maria bartoroma an intel source
telling me that president trump did in
fact
win the election he says that it is up
to the supreme court to hear suits from
other cases across the country
to stop the clock this follows the high
court's refusal to hear the lawsuit
from texas attorney general ken paxton
challenging results in four
swing states now you might say well
david
if an intel source did tell her that
she's not lying she's merely reporting
it
and the intel source could simply be
wrong or mistaken
but is that really the argument you want
to make that's the hill you want to die
on
maria bartiromo is more than 50 years
old and she's been a journalist in some
way shape or form for almost 30 years
and we're standing behind what she said
is okay and responsible to
air as long as some intel person really
did tell her
with no vetting or connection or actual
evidence she says look this is what they
told me
it's actually shocking how maria
bartoromo
has fallen from being a great financial
reporter
to being what is in short a conspiracy
theorist trump suck up that's what she
is at this point
and the the way this relates to my youth
is when i first got into trading stocks
back in the year
2000 when i was in high school i started
watching cnbc because i guess that's
what you do
or at least what you did at the time and
at the time
maria bartoromo really did excellent
interviews of big time fortune 500 ceos
she would hold them accountable her
interview preparation was second to none
she was fantastic and she was the first
tv journalist to report
live from the floor of the new york
stock exchange she won emmys for that
she was well recognized by the italian
american community in new york city
related to her amazing story working her
way up
from her early days in brooklyn as a kid
being a coat checker at her dad's
restaurant i mean it's just an amazing
story
and she was a top-notch interviewer for
more than a decade
and then she joined fox in 2013 things
sort of started to get a little bit
shaky
but then when trump ran in 2016
she developed like an on-air
relationship with trump and got to
interview donald trump and became
essentially
a a dishonest pr person for donald trump
rather than
a journalist which sadly sometimes
happens to people
when they go over to fox news and it
really is sad so
here's my my uh ask of you
don't let this happen to me hold me
accountable i don't think it would
happen but i'm telling you right now if
i do something like this
you can go ahead and cancel your
membership it would be embarrassing and
pathetic
to me to my family to the people that
have supported this show but i'm sure
it's lucrative for her
and who doesn't want to have a friend in
the white house right that is that
that's actually one of the things that
sometimes i i think those who
are only very casual observers of media
don't get
which is that the the appeal
of access to people in power
makes media people do really crazy
things
sometimes and i've said before how
i don't really care about being friends
with politicians
there are a number of elected officials
in the u.s house and in other offices
that
that i'm in touch with and we have what
i guess we would call like personal
relationships but they're not like i'm
you know if they do something wrong and
it's even happened i cover it
and i'm not really impressed i've said
we shouldn't deify these people
but maybe when it gets to a certain
level and it's the president
maybe if the president wants to be your
friend you just repeat whatever nonsense
the president wants you to say i don't
know
but it's really a tragedy what's
happened to maria bartiromo
i have completely unsurprising
not shocking news for you today a
50-year study of tax cuts
has determined that when you give the
very rich tax cuts
things don't trickle down and inequality
actually gets worse
now if you understand economics at all
you would say
david how is this even a story but
there's a large part of this country
that still thinks you give tax cuts to
the rich
money trickles down and it reduces
inequality and everything's good
this is a paper from the london school
of economics and kings college london
and it looked at 50 years of tax cuts
for the wealthy across 18 different
countries
and they evaluated claims like trickle
down
tax cuts for the rich trickle down and
help the economy
or cutting taxes on the rich reduces
inequality and what they found
is that cutting taxes on the rich
increases inequality
gives the rich more money with almost
nothing trickling down below
overall increases in equality and
doesn't improve
economic performance overall it doesn't
lead to economic growth
it doesn't lead to employment growth it
just causes higher income inequality
and one of the things that is important
to understand about this
is that uh there are always going to be
let's divide this up into two ways i
think that for a lot of just average
people
who don't study economics this idea
was always a hard sell i think to just
normal folks who have not been
radicalized to fall for
trickle-down economics if you go to
normal people who just work a job and
don't think too much about it and you
say hey
if we give tax cuts to the really rich
do you think it helps you
you go to a laundromat owner or a
hardware store owner
or a teacher and you say hey we're
giving
billionaires and people with over 50
million in assets we're giving them a
tax cut do you think this will help you
i think that's always been a hard sell
for the average person but there's an
entire movement
that is based around paying
people at think tanks and other places
to claim that tax cuts for the rich are
going to help everybody in some way
and the assumption that really fails is
that when you
cut taxes for the rich more people are
hired
and it fails for a number of different
reasons first of all
most of the money doesn't even enter the
ecosystem of where it would affect
hiring
because rich people have a much higher
savings rate than poor people
if you give a poor person a five percent
reduction
in their tax taxes they're almost
certainly going to spend all of that
money
if you give a really really rich person
a five percent reduction in their taxes
they're going to save most of that money
because they're not counting on that
money to live
and uh as a result because the money is
just being saved
it's not being spent by rich people in a
way that creates
a need for more employees or a need to
pay employees more money
number two even the money that the rich
do spend at a business only part of that
goes to wages
and mostly that additional spending that
the rich do
goes to profits and part of the hard
costs of the things that they are buying
the driver of hiring we know is demand
it's not labor supply
and this is often an argument that's
missing when talking about illegal
immigration or immigration in general
the the argument that
we hear goes they come here legally or
illegally it doesn't for our economic
argument it doesn't matter
they take our jobs and because
they increase the supply of labor
wages go down it's basic economics they
say you bring in a lot more people
looking for work
and companies can pay less and they're
stealing jobs
and lowering wages well remember wages
are only part of the cost of a good or
service
and remember that all of those
immigrants in your community
legal or illegal immigrants they also
buy stuff
they also rent apartments they also buy
food
they go to restaurants so what's missing
from this overly simplistic analysis
is that when you have immigrants come in
looking for work
it's a huge increase to demand because
you have more people demanding products
and services
which under the same simple economic
argument would mean
businesses can raise prices and make
more money right
and people only talk about supply of
labor
to argue against immigration and ignore
the other side of that which is the
demand
increase which is good for businesses
and this has all been demonstrated
academically by countless economic
papers so
what what's missing you know anybody
surprised to get back to the main
article
anybody surprised that over 50 years
in 18 different countries cutting taxes
for the rich didn't trickle down but it
just
increased income inequality you you lack
and i'm not saying this pejoratively you
it sounds like you just lack a more
holistic macroeconomic understanding
of course cutting taxes for the rich
didn't stimulate the economy in the way
that some of these supply ciders think
let me know your thoughts
but a completely unsurprising result
okay we have a voicemail number that
number
is 219 to david p
here is a of increasingly popular
question
about trump and his relationship to
twitter after he's no longer president
hey david i had a quick question so with
the recent
news about donald trump's twitter
account getting those little
information labels underneath his um
disproven
tweets and then recently uh he was
almost soft locked where people couldn't
reply to his tweet
right um because it was proven do you
think that
he eventually once he's no longer
president
do you think that twitter is going to
ban his account and if so do you think
he's going to just try and make a new
one
or do you think he's going to transfer
to a new social media site such as gap
which has more of an alt-right leaning
user base yeah i i think that there's a
really good chance trump gets banned
from twitter when he's no longer
president we've talked already about
section 230
we talked about trump losing world
leader protections on january 20th and i
i do think that if it happens it will be
a
boon for whatever platform trump chooses
to promote that he's switching over to
uh and there's a bunch of different you
know there's parlor there's all these
different
all these different platforms i think
the day trump gets banned from twitter
if it happens and it's announced join us
over on this other app
uh that is going to be a golden a golden
day
for for whichever app donald trump
switches to but yeah i think the risk of
banning being banned from twitter is
really high
we have a great bonus show for you today
we have a california sheriff
refusing to comply with an order to
release
certain inmates due to covet
how is that going to shake out who's
going to win that wall street has
started to trade
water futures as a commodity
i've been warning about this for a
decade
and we're going to have a discussion
about the potential for future water
wars
and then i want to talk a little bit
about the 80 million americans who
chose not to vote at all in this past
election why didn't they vote
npr did a very interesting uh
investigation
and story about the 80 million who did
not vote in this past election
and we will talk about that as well get
instant access to today's bonus show
where i will be joined by producer pat
by signing up at joinpakman.com if you
would like a discount i have a discount
available it's with the coupon code
fresh start all one word all lowercase
no space
fresh start saves you bigly
money dollars bigly money dollars to be
saved using the coupon code fresh start
i'll see you on the bonus gym
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman hydrant is the delicious
fruit drink powder
packed with essential electrolytes for
hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 off go to drink hydrant dot
com slash pacman
and use the code pacman steadymd lets
you maintain a meaningful long lasting
relationship with a primary
care physician who you can meet with
anytime over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started